bonjour nous bouderais bonjour bonjour
aux auditeurs de martinique 1ère
singulièrement ceux du nord de la
martinique et du carbet vous êtes
officiellement candidat à la députation
dans le nord depuis ce week-end pour dit
nous vous pour dit vous plutôt défendre
les intérêts des martiniquais quel
intérêt alors permettez monsieur viol
temps tout d'abord que je puisse
remercier l'ensemble des organisations
qui me soutiennent pour ces élections
législatives circonscription du nord
vous avez vous été prise en vous avez vu
qu'ils avaient l'absence du rdm je ne
désespère pas de ralliement du rdm on se
donne à plein d'autres temps pas encore
je lance un appel aux officielle et
publique à claude lise book
effectivement pour lui dire que c'est
ensemble dans l'unité que nous avons
nous sommes partis à la conquête la
collectivité territoriale et nous avons
gagné
donc c'est ensemble et dans l'unité que
nous partirons à la conquête du nord
pour gagner ces élections ne s'est donc
encore cette unité louis boutrin tout à
fait c'est l'unité du grand ensemble et
qui ne date pas d'aujourd'hui
vous avez bien de l'unité du grand
ensemble est pour bat payant chance
c'est l'unité du rassembler puis ceux
comme vous le savez nous sommes sur des
bases politiques depuis 2010 avec le
rassemblement pour le changement
ensuite lors de la consultation
référendaire pour le 74
ensuite nous avons ensemble
effectivement nous sommes allés à cette
élection pour la collectivité
territoriale et nous travaillons
ensemble
en tout cas votre slogan une énergie
nouvelle pour le nord et ça se
caractériserait comment selon vous alors
une énergie nouvelle c'est parce que
quand on fait le bilan de l'actuelle des
buts et on voit bien que c'est un bilan
autres pleuvent aujourd'hui il va bien
falloir aller poser les véritables
problèmes prendre les véritables
décisions qui se prennent à l'assemblée
nationale pourquoi en trompe l'oeil
parce que il vous a soutenu un moment
ensuite il a changé de nom je ne je ne
viendrai pas sur ces moments de trahison
puisque vous le rappeler effectivement
bruno nestor azérot avait été a été élu
grand en 2012 grâce mois et vous l'avez
rappelé avant d'y alfred marie-jeanne et
de claude lise
et qu'ensuite il a appelé à barrer la
route à la liste conduite par alfred
marie jeanne
mais je crois que son sort était réglé
le 13 décembre dans les urnes
maintenant ce que nous disons
aujourd'hui il y à des enjeux
particuliers
cette élection qui arrive là ce n'est
pas une élection comme les autres c'est
une élection qui se passe dans son
contexte particulier quand vous avez vu
un contexte de crise politique grave
crise à la fois sociétal moral
institutionnel avec des affaires la
vaste affaire nauséabonde et surtout il
faut le dire
à quelques jours des présidentielles la
tentation des extraits mise et du
populisme qui menace les fondements même
de notre démocratie donc nous avons
besoin dans cette situation monsieur
viol ton et de députés qui saura
défendre les intérêts de la matinée
grâce aux mines selon la députée avec
une certaine moralité en politique c'est
un des arguments pour votre candidature
mais qui peut aujourd'hui évoquer cette
moralité alors que la population quand
même de plus en plus critique vis-à-vis
des élus oui la population a tout à fait
et le droit effectivement d'être
critique comme la population critique
vis-à-vis de certaines professions ou
dix finalistes
vous avez dès lors qu'il ya quelques
déviance il faut sanctionner ces
méfiances et si on ne sanctionne pas ses
déviances comme on l'a vu récemment au
niveau des candidats à l'élection
présidentielle
certains candidats qui sont convoqués
par la justice qui ne viennent pas
qu'est ce que vous laissez pour le
justiciable me moyens bridoux très vous
voulez vous appuyez sur votre action en
tant que conseiller exécutif sur
l'action d'un septième pour démontrer
votre engagement votre efficacité votre
capacité à mener son mandat de député
mais quelque part est juge et partie
il ya m'a quand même quelques-uns qui
disent que le pays est à l'arrêt il
faudra les convaincre
oui mais ça c'est sa suite d'une une
appréciation du mauvais perdant
les indicateurs économiques et sociaux
démontrent le contraire donc on ne va
pas pinailler là dessus le moment
viendra en a déjà fait un bilan de la
première année de mandature de la cité m
et en moins de nom nous avons énormément
fait je prends un exemple classique 1
vous voyez ne serait-ce qu'en matière
d'énergie en une année nous avons gagné
un gain de 27 me
lyon de kilowattheures 27 millions c'est
un record qui est nouveau jamais par le
passé on avait un match à 2015 énergie
atteint un tel record ce qui nous a
permis de gagner deux points et de faire
reculer notre dépendance énergétique
voilà un exemple et je pourrais citer
celui des transports où vous avez bien
compris que malgré les difficultés qu'il
y avait pour organiser les transports
nous avons pu mettre ce n'est pas une
ouverture sur la question des des
transformations pour vous sur votre
programme vous parlez de l'emploi
durable vous ai fait très mal insisté
sur l'accès au savoir dans cette zone de
lille face à un illettrisme galopant
lorsqu'on regarde les chiffres du doigt
du nord de l'île par rapport au centre
et au sud tout à fait parce que le nom
n'est pas une circonscription comme les
autres il y a une fracture territoriale
et le nord méritent une attention
particulière et si on prend le cas de
l'emploi
on remarque que la carte de l'emploi la
carte du chômage correspond étrangement
à la carte de l'éducation ou la cadre du
nombre de diplômés c'est l'assaut lundi
yahoo le député qui peut agir là-dessus
justement c'est l'argent vient c'est
l'action du député parce que l'accès au
savoir l'éducation et l'information pour
lutter contre cette spirale de
l'illettrisme et du chômage qui frappe
particulièrement le nord c'est à
l'assemblée nationale que l'on pourra
prendre des mesures et défendre les
dossiers pour cette circonscription nord
c'est la même chose pour les retraites
la précarité la lutte contre l'exclusion
c'est la même chose puisque comme vous
le savez en matière économique par
exemple pour la réforme du code des
marchés publics la lutte contre la
précarité et l'exclusion
ce sont des politiques nationales qui
qui qui se prennent et la continuité
territoriale
vous savez bien qu'actuellement on peut
aller facilement avec 180 euros à new
york
à lire ochoa locaux pour aller à pointe
à pitre et 250 euros alors là il ya
nouvelle policiers par exemple sortir de
ce genre d'argumentation comme la lutte
contre la hausse des tarifs ce combat
pour la continuité territoriale est un
parti qui en ont assez d'entendre ça je
me suis vraiment dans les personnes
âgées monsieur vient finances monsieur
la ceinture réalité vous tombe images je
tiens à l'assemblée nationale en train
de défendre à l'époque avec patrick
karam ce dossier de la continuité
territoriale
résultat aujourd'hui leurs résultats
aujourd'hui c'est que nous n'avons pas
pu justement sceller dans le marbre et
celle heureux c'est ça qui fait mal aux
martiniquais saisi par des candidats
comme vous avancez ce genre de choses et
puis finalement les choses les choses
restent en l'état tant qu'elles ne sont
pas scellées donc vous me donnez tout à
fait raison qu'il faut aller à
l'assemblée nationale faire en sorte que
ses décisions
et quand il ya une loi qu'il y ait des
décrets d'application qu'ils soient pris
pour que ça soit scellée dans le mauvais
goût de ce qui s'est fait en corse il y
a eu une continuité territoriale qui a
été décrété au niveau de la poste
maintenant on en parle plus les élus co2
de la porsche s'est sorti de leur dispo
parce que c'est un faible maintenant eux
ils ont su faire vous les remettre la
question institutionnelle sur le tapis
pourquoi parce qu'aujourd'hui vous avez
bien vu et l'exemple de la guyane nous
le montre qu'ils les limites du système
actuel
vous avez bien compris que beaucoup de
décisions se prennent
en dehors de la martinique et qui ne
favorise pas un développement endogène
ce que je dis aujourd'hui il nous faut
sortir des sempiternelles querelles
politiciennes en avant tendu sur la
troisième voie ou sur les chiffres pour
elle de chiffres entre articles 73 et 74
parce qu'il s'agit de développement du
gène magique
on doit encore à cette question mais
c'est avec des dd je dirais des
commentaires de l'as autres
qu'effectivement on décourage les bonnes
initiatives
il faut pouvoir et je prendrai le temps
monsieur vol viol temps d'expliquer
qu'il y a des principes essentiels comme
le principe de subsidiarité qui est un
principe de la charte de l'autonomie
locale et qui est introduit dans le
droit communautaire à l'article 5 du
traité de maastricht et que ce principe
nous permet aujourd'hui et permet à
l'état de déléguer une partie de ses
pouvoirs aux collectivités territoriales
quand l'état considère que ces
collectivités territoriales sont mieux à
même de les assumer
compte tenu de la proximité avec les
citoyens il s'agit donc plus monsieur le
temps pour les instances territoriales
comme les nôtres
le plaquer des dispositifs qui sont
conçus au niveau national pour répondre
à des problématiques endogène et
sectorielles il s'agit désormais pour
les martiniquais d'organiser la
coordination est d'associer de manière
croisée l'ensemble des outils
institutionnels indispensable à la mise
en oeuvre d'un développement endogène
maintenant que nous avons cette
opportunité nous allons pouvoir mettre
en place des politiques sectorielles que
ce soit des politiques de développement
humain comme le sport comme également la
formation et l'éducation des politiques
économiques
tout cela monsieur viol ton permettait
il s'agit
ce n'est pas aux réductions 6,90 ce
n'est pas au coin d'une table que ça se
conçoit
ça se conçoit dans le bain dans une
thèse de doctorat en droit
constitutionnel
et c'est cela l'atout que j'apporte mes
par magma candidature dernière question
louis boutrin vous êtes conseiller
exécutif en charge du sport de
l'environnement du développement durable
de l'énergie de la croissance verte du
transport du sport vous êtes président
également dû du parc naturel pourquoi
être aussi boulimique
mais je ne suis pas du tout boulimique
je suis conseiller exécutif
on m'a confié l'émission jacques ses
missions sans les trahir
j'essaie de les assumer la seule chose
que j'ai demandée
c'était effectivement la présidence du
parc naturel mais pour le reste ce sont
des missions qualifiez vous serez à
organiser ce sont des missions qui m'ont
été confiées par alfred marie jeanne
merci d'avoir été avec nos louis boutrin
on rappelle que vous êtes candidat à la
députation dans le nord est votre slogan
une énergie nouvelle pour l'honneur
merci beaucoup merci à vous
[Musique]